Wow late night video late night upload
just learned news that was pretty
unexpected so after the Internet raged
out about the Sonic the Hedgehog trailer
dish bags like that guy what a dick
there was a release someone sent it to
me on Instagram I believe it was the
director who was like alright we hear
yeah we want to make him the best Sonic
he could be so we'll change his
appearance we'll fix it to look more
like the game I really that works like
the collective internet just raged out
this dude was like okay I'll take that
constructive criticism that's awesome I
mean it actually kind of makes me feel
bad at the fact I just bitched about the
trailer I just think that's really
mature it's so easy you know the
Internet can be a very volatile place a
very vocal loud angry place when it
doesn't get their way it's easy to
resist that kind of energy coming at you
or your property that you're working on
with opposing energy of equal force my
way of saying angry people make for
angry responses a lot of the time like a
fans are like [ __ ] that I didn't like
that a lot of times the director will be
like deal with it dicks this dude was
like alright I'll take that to heart I
don't always do that it's so easy people
like though it was stupid I'm like I try
not to be like a conscious effort to be
mature about stuff but I'm just saying
that it deserves to be commended I just
like mature responsive it's been like a
day of mature responses like
blood-stained ritual of night really
looking forward to it my friends and I
have been looking forward to that for a
while now we finally found out we're
getting that game like next month I mean
the demos came out it was easy to see
graphically it wasn't as polished or
advanced as a lot of other games on
these systems I was just like it looks
like a crowdfunded game because it is in
fact a crowdfunded game fans were like
either geographically it looks kind of
like acid the director was like you know
what I'm gonna prove you wrong and they
polished the hell out of the graphics
cues the fans had a thing or two to say
about the graphics I thought that was a
mature response I think what they're
doing with Sonic is a mature response
that at least shows that they want to
make it good they're like make trying to
make right by the fans so right there is
for Sonic the Hedgehog I kind of just
wrote it off as like alright that looks
like [ __ ] now I'm like well I mean
you're trying so I mean I'll take it in
now I'm interested to see the final
product because you want to do right by
the fans not
saying the movie looks great I'm saying
the response from the director is great
and that ain't nothing because in the
end he could have just as easily been
like whatever [ __ ] you deal with it
no here here's the here's what they say
it'll make sense when you watch it and
it never does that's director code for
we're not gonna change it now so it is
what it is you didn't say that that's
cool what I don't want our fans to be
like well now he looks too cartoony and
stupid that'll just show people that
there's no winning on the internet so if
you make something that might be dumb
why change it is you're gonna go through
all that effort to change it and people
are still gonna [ __ ] so why change it I
don't want that to happen I don't want
that to be the outcome just as someone
who got on camera and bitched about the
Sonic the Hedgehog trailer I feel like I
should at least update you on this I
know just mature responses they deserve
to be praised it's a good job dude all
right so Sonic the Hedgehog getting a
reskin to look more accurate to the game
because Internet what do you think about
that whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you wanna see
more click right here to see more
[Music]